[Music]
[Applause]
he's a six-time All-Star won the MVP
back in 2010
Red's first baseman Joey Votto Reds
Rockies today 12 35 Eastern 10-game
winning streak how do you not screw up a
good thing like you get on a streak so
you come back
how do you how does a team like do you
are you superstitious going into this
Dan hello I I uh I'm a regular now on
the show by the way I want to be uh
introduced as a regular to the show Joey
Votto uh friend of ours yeah
Joey Votto
okay let me try that again
six-time All-Star won the MVP back in
2010 Red's first baseman our good buddy
R Powell and uh one of us Joey Votto
joining us on the program
go away
okay uh welcome back by the way yeah
good to be back uh to answer your
question the first night I performed
well and that helps a lot had I come
back and you know Fallen flat on my face
and we had lost
I would have heard about it it would
have been I would have been
I would have been tied to you know they
would have thought of me
like a loser like I would have been like
oh Joe is back so we start to lose so I
I perform well thank goodness and uh we
ended up getting a win
what's the difference though last year
this team loses a hundred games now
you're in first place
yeah uh players we've got through we've
got
three uh I'm missing guys I'm gonna miss
guys but we've three position player
rookies that are new to the team that
are that a lot of people are asking to
be on the All-Star team now do you know
everybody on your team
um there's a there's a few guys where I
don't know how to spell their first or
last names okay and there's a couple
guys where I have to handshake hello at
the very beginning of the day hey so
good to see uh meet you you know and
we've been on this team together for a
bit and then you and then you look at
the back of their Jersey to be like oh
De La Cruz yes yes yes yes yes no I I
was in Louisville for like the last
three months so I know these guys well
um I know and then all the rest of the
guys I've played with for a bit but it's
the young guys we've got these three uh
young position players we've got another
fellow TJ Friel everything about our
team is different and everyone is
playing well you know I I was thinking
about this last night because I knew
that you and I were gonna chat and I was
thinking about how can I liken how can I
explain what we're doing differently
here and it's like it's like we went
from being a post team in the NBA where
they would dump it in to me and I would
slow down the offense and you know Bank
a shot or whatever whatever uh to all of
a sudden we're a running gun type of
Team like the Warriors or like the Kings
what have you and these guys are fast
they're powerful uh they play uh premium
positions they are the type of a
baseball that if I were a fan I would
pay to watch so it we're so fortunate
here I mean these guys are absolutely
the future of the game
you know it's small things that stand
out to me when it comes to Greatness and
watching De La Cruz
a grounder to third is not a grounder to
third it's an opportunity to beat out a
hit and there are a lot of young players
that will Coast on something like that
this kid goes full speed there was a
grounder to First that he beat out the
other night like that I don't know if
you teach it but man does he have it he
wants he wants to you know make sure
that he gives you every ounce he has
he's he's
a joy to watch a joy to watch a joy to
play with and he he wants to use his
speed he knows that it's part one of his
strengths but he also knows that people
come to watch him run and I you know I
watched I was in Louisville and there
was a second baseman that made a tag at
second base and he was at third base
and the second baseman turned his back
and made a tag and he ran home and he
was safe at the plate like he's going to
do some things and you're going to see
them on what you know highlights and you
won't understand how he did it couple
that with he has the most power maybe in
the game he's up easily up there with
Judge John Carlo
he's you know he's he's he's everything
you could ask for in a prospect and
where we have him here in Cincinnati
where does that power come from
[Music]
from well
I can't say hair because I have power
he's got great hair I've got no hair but
we both have power I would say probably
he's 21. he probably got no sleep last
night you're probably playing video
games all night uh I know I know
Chipotle was involved and you know he
just has it he just has it he reminds me
of Eric Davis a little bit
I don't think Eric's my guy Eric's my
guy but if Eric had this sort of power I
I he's gonna hit some balls we're gonna
see him at home his build like oh he's
taller he's taller but yeah very similar
build in terms of slight build you know
small smaller sort of uh wiry build but
he's just electricity you know I I have
to ask his permission uh uh what
um uh nickname I want to give him
because there's one I want to share
publicly but I I can't I have to ask his
permission first so
um it involves extraterrestrials but I
won't I won't go farther than that so
well I'll hold on if you want to get a
hold of him and ask him
it involves UFOs and extraterrestrials
okay Ellie De La Cruz Ellie De La Cruz
okay if you had a race with him and you
started at home plate do you get to
second before he gets home I gotta I
buddy who I had this conversation with
about Billy Hamilton who runs probably
as well maybe not quite as well as Ellie
De La Cruz and he said if I got drunk
and I started at first base
at the Rogers Center in Toronto or at
Great American Ballpark here because
he's from Toronto if I got drunk and
he's Billy Billy Hamilton started from
home all the way to home plate uh and I
started from first I would beat him he
said and I said there's no way there's
no way you could beat him and he gets
all miffed about it at least with me if
I started at first base I know Ellie's
gonna beat me I would have to get a
secondary lead for me to stand any
chance of beating him to home play and
he would laugh at me as he chases me
down so yeah
you would you might get to second before
he rounded the bases and got to home if
you started at home plate both of you
I'd barely get the third if he's he'd
get to he'd get to home and I barely get
to third oh no I I'm a good player here
Dan I'm a really good player and you're
making me feel like I'm
trying out you know well you're not
known for your speed
right oh you know I used to uh but you
used to but but you used to take a pitch
off the plate and then get a broken bat
single and then get another walk and I'd
be one for two with two walks
that's pretty cool give me uh Joey
votto's stolen bases career or single
season High I have the most stolen bases
in this Clubhouse
you're the only one there
he's got Canadian speed Dan he's got 80
career stolen bases and a high of 16 in
2010 yes okay and and people haven't
been stealing bases
well well you know somebody some of us
haven't some of us don't okay when you
go to the plate you've been rehabbing
you had shoulder surgery you go up to
the plate
you trying to hit a home run
of course
today maybe one possibly two
you can give me a home run today you can
give this audience a home run today is
that what you're saying oh my God you
know all of us here you know it's it'd
be it'd be emotional okay it'd be like
this I promise you right now okay
I'm going to try I'm going to try
that's not what Babe Ruth said to that
little boy in the hospital bed ah that's
just that's uh who is that actor well
anyways you really think you said that
yeah you really I think he did I think I
think babe probably a little uh hung
over said ah I'm gonna hit a home run
for you Kelly yeah all right probably he
probably did you probably did I noticed
the walk-up songs have they changed as
you've gotten older
yeah and you know I think I being more
serious I think more about the
grandparents and the kids and the
grandkids that come to the games no I
think about like not disrespecting them
with some of the questionable language
okay all right okay tell me tell me if
these are Truth Hurts by lizzo
yes you use that one I think so I don't
I don't remember but the truth does hurt
sometimes Dan uh Lucifer by Jay-Z yes
the blacker the berry by Kendrick Lamar
yes
humble by Kendrick Lamar
you have to stay humble
Murder She Wrote
a great show in the 80s yes it was she
was hot uh that's that's not appropriate
okay uh work to do by The Isley Brothers
no I don't think so but maybe I you know
maybe I don't remember Paint It Black by
the stone now why would you do painted
black when that's for a pitcher
uh no it starts off by saying I see a
red door and I want to paint it black so
if there's one if there's one song that
people drive me crazy about walking back
out to again it's that one because
everybody breaks into Applause
afterwards when that that kicks in and
uh it just it's a good song but it's not
for me yeah because pitchers Paint It
Black yeah you don't you don't want like
you know someone like Clayton Kershaw to
paint it black
a Hall of Famer yeah yeah
yeah who's the pitcher you're gonna tell
your kids about grandkids about you're
like yep face two
Frank Kershaw's pretty clearly one of
them uh he's you know he's he's
he's the new Colfax of the Dodgers okay
but describe that when you know I he
could tell you he's thrown the breaking
ball probably right no no no no no no no
no no no that's not how it works with me
no no
uh you can't tell me you can't I'm
compete I'm I'm not gonna go there and
like uh Punky at bat just because
Clayton Kershaw I mean I've homered off
of him and I've called homers against
him he's more more or less what do you
mean called homers
uh we were both rookies and I told the
third baseman on their team I was going
to Homer and then I said that and he
said you do realize who's pitching right
and I Homer the next next event he goes
you mother you know
[Laughter]
yeah but you know Clayton's more or less
dominant and dominated me and almost all
hitters during our career so uh during
my career excuse me so um but Clayton's
probably the one Mariano Rivera who I
old Yankee Stadium
I homered off of Mike Museum in my first
event there's the last time my late
father got to see me play he was you
know in the stands I homered he watched
the whole series and I really wanted to
face mariana rivera before the series
was over and I happened to face him I
believe in my last at-bat before we left
you know old Yankee Stadium what an
experience Jeter and the Yankees went
experience you could feel the ghosts and
then I get to face Mariano who was
basically getting an inning in well I
decided you know I I'm gonna you know
choke up and like catch the cutter out
front and it went and it just kept
coming kept coming I ended up check
swinging grounder to Third Base A-Rod
picked it up I was safe at first that's
back when I had roughly Ellie De La Cruz
Speed okay that's probably I'm probably
out by eight maybe 12 feet so yeah
uh so he is promising at least one home
run today for the audience at least one
at least one
yes it is oh no so I have to come
through oh no Dan you have you will have
an hour before first pitch oh my
goodness I have to come through well
make sure that you bury this okay it
doesn't come through laud me
praise me I should be trending on
Twitter
are you staying around to pass Larry
Walker on the all-time Canadian hit list
ing around
um do you want to play do you want to
continue to play
see I didn't bring up Hall of Fame this
time
no no no no and I've been we're not
doing that anymore we're not doing that
it's I'm clearly not one it's over why
are we even talking about exactly we're
not going to bring that up
um I I don't think by the way if you get
in the Hall of Fame I'm I'm going to the
ceremony come on Dan I
I promise a friend of the show sort of
rule yes is that did you go to Reggie's
yeah if I don't have anything going on
in 10 years from now if I'm still alive
I will be there I'll pay for your ticket
on Spirit or Frontier
last row but it'll be a window seat
You're Gonna Hear Me applauding you're
gonna hear me yeah
yeah I'm going to say that the Wayne
Gretzky of baseball
no don't disrespect Wayne like that I'm
a fight player I'm no Wayne Gretzky
Wayne's the greatest maybe athlete of
the last 25 years not named Jordan
Gretzky nicer than you
God is 45 years for Gretzky Gretzky
you're pretty you're a pretty nice guy
most of us are behind the scenes this is
all an act
ual Korean act most of us behind the
scenes are
not friendly people
how can we be friendly and compete you
know it's uh and more importantly We're
Stars and we make all the money and
people want our autograph after a while
it's like
no ones are equal sort of thing so no
I'm not nice behind the scenes okay fair
enough he guarantees at least one home
run do not talk to him about its Hall of
Fame he has deceptive speed he's not
hanging around to pass Larry Walker
yeah
anything else
no in front of the show and friend of
the show
I I miss I missed when I had my surgery
last year it was about 10 months ago
and I should have reached out I should
have reached out when you're having
surgery that's okay I appreciate the
flowers but before the surgery I thought
it's going to be a while before I'm on
Dan's show
and I wonder what color hoodie he's
gonna wear turns out he picked
do we have our Friday song queued up do
we have that no no no no no no no no no
no do we have the song we play on Friday
when we close up shot
Todd Rundgren
do we have that because I do have a
walk-up song for you oh nice yeah how
about this uh low-key
Loki uh
Sports Illustrated cover yeah I saw that
that's very hot that Margie do you have
it
okay here is your walk up song
Crank It Up Now
ladies and gentlemen first baseman Joey
Votto Don't Call Him a Hall of Famer he
doesn't want to talk about it deceptive
speed he's old here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
all day
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you thinking well the audio on
my end is not so good but I'll pretend
like I loved it so I don't want to work
I just want to bang on the drum all day
I swear I love to do that I would love
okay it's Todd Rundgren uh-huh
I don't want to work I just want to bang
on the drum all day later ladies and
gentlemen first baseman Joey Votto on
that note I gotta run okay all right you
got to get ready for a couple of home
runs thank you Joey take care thanks
Joey Votto he's a nice guy on TV but not
in real life
he's something nailed it yes he is yes
he is
uh thank you to the Cincinnati Reds for
helping us with that